like was it named after popcorn or was
it named popcorn because popcorn was
invented there so apparently if I score
the lowest I have to drink a giant
concoction of all of the answers the
stakes are high on this one I'm not
feeling great popcorn Indiana that has
to be fake right that has to be fake the
way you said it makes me think you were
just making it up off the spot that's
not a real place hmm I would love for
that to be a real place I feel like I
would know I would have heard of this
I'm gonna say fake huh bless the
citizens of popcorn Indiana what I don't
know what Alabama
however Alabama would be associated with
soup I want to say soup Alabama it's
true it does exist I want to play it
safe this time I'm gonna say that one is
not real soup Alabama it's not real good
it's like super Alabama just sounds
silly it sounds like a really bad porn
thank you
kind of like rolls off your tongue which
is nice this is crazy who's from hot
coffee Mississippi please like find me
and tell me who you are
chilly Wisconsin I'm from Wisconsin I
don't remember a city named chilly is
there Wisconsin chilly chilly Wisconsin
is a real place no no I'm so good at
this that doesn't sound like crazy oh
man this okay if this isn't real no
that's not real I think there is another
city like that but I don't think a
Pennsylvania is real
[Music]
[ __ ] and that just sound like them the
name of the town in every hallmark movie
I can't drink anything with mayo you
know I don't want it to be a real place
because that's so obvious I would be
more suspicious of mayonnaise Florida
let's say but Mayo Florida that could
exist of course Florida's gotta meet
host North Carolina shoot Google with my
gut it's real yeah this is real because
I know this is a real City I know toes
who named all of these towns like this
land shall be named toast
yeah yes we good
this is
[Music]